MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
And welcome to Authors
in Google in Cambridge.
Today, it's my
very great pleasure
to introduce Stephen Kinzer.
We'll be discussing his
newest book, "The Brothers.
John Foster Dulles, Allen Dulles
and their Secret World War."
Stephen Kinzer is an
award-winning foreign
correspondent who
has unflinchingly
covered more than 50
countries on five continents
for newspapers including
the "Boston Globe"
and the "New York Times,"
over a career that
has spanned more
than four decades,
during which time many
people in positions of power,
I'm guessing, have
wished he had chosen
a different line of work.
He currently teaches journalism
and international relations
at Boston University,
contributes articles
to the "New York Review of
Books" and the "Daily Beast"
and writes a world affairs
column for the "Guardian."
"The Brothers" is his ninth
book on international affairs.
The story of the Dulles
brothers is a story
of the creation of the US
intelligence community,
of the beginning of US covert
actions around the world,
and of the overthrow of
foreign governments in the name
of democracy and the interests
of the giant corporations
the brothers spent
their careers serving.
"The Brothers" places
their extraordinary lives
against the background of
American culture and history
using the framework of biography
to ask why does the United
States behave as it
does in the world?
Please join me in
welcoming Stephen Kinzer.
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHEN KINZER: OK,
thanks for that.
It's wonderful to be here.
I feel like I'm in some kind
of an inner sanctum at Google.
I was told not to write anything
about this, which was not
asked of me when
I spoke recently
at the State Department.
Or when I spoke recently at
the National Security Agency.
I'm glad to hear that this
is going to be on YouTube.
But I have a feeling
that given where we are,
it's probably
going out right now
to a few places we
can't even imagine.
I should point out just
after that lush introduction
that I no longer teach
at Boston University.
I'm now a Fellow at
the Watson Institute
for International
Studies at Brown.
Also, I'm trying to
focus on, in my teaching
and writing, some of the
same issues that come out
in this book that we're
talking about today.
Actually, the digitization
of the book-selling industry
has had a cute
little effect for me
as I've been speaking about this
current book, "The Brothers."
I've always had a
slight pang when
I've gone into bookstores
and look for my books.
Not because I don't
find them, I actually
have graduated from that.
That's more of a pang.
That's really a wince.
But I go into the bookstore,
and I usually find my books
in some section like Current
History or Modern American
Politics or something like that.
And those books are then
organized alphabetically.
And what often happens to me,
as it just happened this week
when I stopped into
Barnes and Noble,
that my book, because
of my name being Kinzer,
is always next to a
book by Henry Kissinger.
I've never really liked that.
But it's simply
seems to be my fate.
I did not, however, account
on a wonderful change
that has happened.
I'm now noticing it
for the first time
with this book, "The Brothers."
So nowadays, of
course, many people
are buying their
books on Amazon.
And Amazon alphabetizes their
books in a different way.
First of all, there
are no categories.
It's just from A to
Z. And it's by title.
So when I look for
my book on Amazon,
I type in "The Brothers,"
and it comes up.
That's the first book.
And the very next book after
me is "The Brothers Karamazov."
So I'm going from Henry
Kissinger to Dostoevsky.
And I feel like I'm in much
more amenable company now.
So if I don't achieve
anything else with this book,
I think I've already
accomplished something
thanks to the way that
book buying is changing.
Now, it's been very interesting
for me learning about
and writing about and speaking
about the Dulles brothers,
starting with the obvious fact.
And that's this.
In the 1950s, John Foster
Dulles was Secretary of State.
His younger brother Allen
was Director of the CIA.
It was the only time in history
that brothers controlled
the overt and the covert sides
of American foreign policy.
They were hugely powerful.
They could make and
break governments.
And they did.
Possibly, there was hardly a
literate human being on Earth
who did not know
the name Dulles.
But now, they're almost
completely forgotten.
We've essentially airbrushed
them out of history.
I used to hate the idea
that airport in Washington
was named after
John Foster Dulles.
But now I'm grateful,
because without that, we
wouldn't remember
his name at all.
And I start out in my
book with a story that
talks about how I began
working on this project.
Since I was going to be writing
about the Dulles brothers,
I found the YouTube video
where President Kennedy
opened that airport
in the early '60s.
And he has a nice ceremony.
Former President
Eisenhower's there.
Allen Dulles was there.
The widow of Foster Dulles
and various dignitaries.
Kennedy made a
nice little speech.
Then he pulled the
curtain back, and there
was the big bust of
John Foster Dulles that
stands in the middle
of Dulles Airport.
And as I stared at that clip,
I started asking myself,
I never saw--
where is that bust?
I've been through
Dulles Airport.
I wasn't really looking for it.
But if it stands right in
front of the reflecting pool,
as I see on this video,
I must have gone by it.
So I arranged to go through
Dulles Airport on my next trip.
And I asked the security
guard to direct me
to the Dulles bust,
and nobody could.
And then I finally
said, well, I know
it's right in front of
the reflecting pool.
And then I was told there is
no reflecting pool in Dulles
airport.
Sure enough, it's
a very long story,
but it turns out that
in the late '90s,
there was a renovation
at Dulles Airport.
The reflecting
pool was filled in.
The bust disappeared.
I was never able to
figure out who ordered it.
And through many phone calls and
emails, I was taken to see it.
It's now in a closed
conference room
opposite Baggage Claim Number 3.
And that really shows you what's
happened to the Dulles brothers
in our historical memory.
So in my book, I'm trying
to bring them back to life.
I think part of the problem
we as Americans often
have is that we lack
a historical memory.
We think that things
that happened today
must have just been
stimulated by things
that happened within
the last few weeks.
But that's not true.
Countries that have existed
for much longer than we have,
like China and Iran, understand
countries go up and down.
There are cycles of history.
And you can't get away
with violently intervening
in the political affairs
of other countries,
without that having
some kind of effect,
even if that affect
does not become
clear until years or decades
or even generations later.
So within the framework of
the biography of the Dulles
brothers, I'm also looking
for the roots of some
of America's
problems in the world
and hoping that we can draw
some lessons from the Dulles
brothers.
So let me talk a little
bit about who they were
and what their background was.
One of the themes I try
to make clear in my book
is that the Dulles
brothers really
reflect a lot about America.
In a sense, they're
quite extraordinary.
But on the other hand,
the forces that shaped
them are very much the forces
that shaped our country.
So what were those?
I'm going to cite three
forces that I think
were very important in shaping
the Dulles brothers and the way
they saw the world.
They grew up in a little town
called Watertown, New York,
on the shores of
Lake Ontario, which
was kind of a playground
for the New York rich.
Their father was a clergyman.
And they grew up under the
wing of their grandfather--
it was truly an
extraordinary family-- who
had been Secretary of
State in the 1890s.
In fact, he was the
first Secretary of State
to preside over the US overthrow
of a foreign government.
That was in Hawaii 1893.
So maybe it was something
genetic already in the family.
So the two boys grew up
with their grandfather, who
had been Secretary of
State, and their uncle,
who also became
Secretary of State.
So John Watson Foster was
the bewhiskered old man
who, with his nephew
Robert Lansing,
would take the two boys off
every morning on fishing trips
around Lake Ontario and
the adjoining streams.
And these were not just trips
to stock the wily small mouth
bass.
They were great lessons
in American history.
John Watson Foster,
the grandfather,
had lived the classic
American pioneer
life in the age of
manifest destiny.
He had gone to the West and
civilized the empty terrain
and fought the savages
and become prominent
and built his way into
influence and rose
to diplomatic
positions, including
finally Secretary of State.
He transmitted to his
grandsons this idea
that we call American
exceptionalism, the idea
that the United States
had a providential mission
in the world.
And it was to spread its
influence and its wisdom
to all the benighted peoples
who were not wise enough
to see that the
American way of life
was destined to take
over the whole world.
He thought of that
as a philosophy
that he would follow
inside North America.
But, of course, by the time the
grandchildren came to power,
they were projecting
American influence
around the world
in the nuclear age.
So that would have been one
big force that shaped them.
They came from an
extraordinary family.
In the winter times, they
would go to Washington
and spend months that
their grandfather's house.
And there, the
dinner guests would
be Woodrow Wilson
and Grover Cleveland,
Bernard Baruch and
Andrew Carnegie
and a parade of senators
and ambassadors and cabinet
secretaries.
So from a very young age,
they absorbed the attitudes
and the vocabulary of
the American elite.
In fact, Allen Dulles,
the younger brother,
when he was still
10, 12 years old,
would go up to bed
after these dinners.
They were not allowed
to participate
in the conversations, of
course, but could listen.
And he would write reports
to himself of everybody
who attended and what they
said and what he, young Ally,
thought they really meant
behind what they said.
Here's a future director of the
CIA before the agency has even
been created, who
already has this impulse
to be writing down his
impressions of other people.
So, this atmosphere, growing
up in this extraordinary family
and receiving this message
of American exceptionalism,
I think, was very important
for the Dulles brothers
as it is for many of us.
A second big factor that shaped
them was missionary Calvinism.
So, as I said, the
father was a clergymen.
The grandfather was a clergyman.
The great grandfather
was a clergyman.
The uncles were clergyman.
Many were missionaries too.
At the Dulles household,
when they were boys,
there was often a
returning missionary
who had spend time
in China or in Syria,
talking about how great were the
trials and rewards of going out
into the world and
trying to civilize it.
Missionary Calvinism,
first of all,
teaches there's good and
evil forces in the world.
Not like some other cultures,
which teach that all of us
and all regimes and
all systems are made up
of good and evil influences,
and these come out
in different
proportions, according
to different situations.
The Dulles brothers did
not grow up believing that.
They believed that were
forces of good and evil
and that the good,
that is the Christians,
didn't have the luxury
of sitting at home
and just hoping for
the triumph of good.
The missionary ethos tells you
have to go out in the world
and assure the triumph of good.
So if you believe
that about religion,
it's just a short step to
believing the same thing
about politics, that we have
some regimes in the world that
are based on pure,
good, godly principles.
Then there's the evil bad ones.
And the good ones are
responsible for going out
and crushing the bad ones.
That would be a second big force
that I think shaped the Dulles
brothers and also is an
impulse that shapes America.
The final big force in shaping
them was the decades that they
spent working for this
unique Wall Street law firm
called Sullivan and Cromwell.
This was not a law
firm like any other.
If you really need
a contract drawn up
or you need to be
represented in the courtroom,
they had people
who could do that.
But this was not why anybody
hired Sullivan Cromwell.
That law firm had a specialty.
It was pushing around
small countries
to do what big American
corporations wanted them to do.
That's why every big American
multinational corporation
hired Sullivan and Cromwell.
John Foster Dulles was
the managing partner
of Sullivan and
Cromwell for decades.
And Allen Dulles also worked
there for extended periods.
So this became their life.
Just to give one example, soon
after John Foster Dulles came
to the firm, when he was
still a young associate,
they got a case from
their clients in Cuba.
There they had the sugar
growers, the cement
manufacturers and
the railroad owners,
and a group of mining concerns.
What had happened?
Bad news from Cuba.
There'd been an election.
The liberals had won.
The liberals had as
part of their platform
limiting the amount of
land that farmers could own
and imposing taxes on
foreign-owned enterprises.
So these enterprises came
to Sullivan and Cromwell
and said you've got to make
this problem go away for us.
The case went to
John Foster Dulles.
The next morning he
got on the train,
and he went to Washington to
see Uncle Bert, otherwise known
as Secretary of
State Robert Lansing.
He explained the problem.
And Lansing asked him, what
do you think we should do?
Young lawyer Dulles said,
we should send two warships
to Cuba in the area where
the revolution is going on.
The liberals were rebelling
against the refusal
of the conservatives
to recognize
the result of the election.
The next morning the
two warships were sent.
6,000 Marines debarked in Cuba.
They put down the
liberal revolution.
Everything was fine
for the companies.
No taxes were imposed.
No restrictions on American
ownership were passed.
And the occupation lasted
for another six years.
Cubans got a little bit angrier,
but we didn't notice that
until a few decades later.
So that's what John
Foster Dulles and Allen
Dulles did for a living.
And when you have
spent that much time
as such esteemed and
highly paid courtiers
for the American
plutocracy, you naturally
begin to absorb its perspective,
which is based on the idea
that what's good for American
multinational corporations
should be the basis of
American foreign policy.
And that's the idea they
took with them into office.
In fact, towards the end of
their stay in private law,
just as they were moving
into their positions of power
in the early '50s, they found a
couple of enemies in the world.
And I think they took
up a couple of grudges
that they brought
with them into power.
Two things happened
in the early 1950s
that were very bad for
Sullivan and Cromwell clients--
clients of the Dulles brothers.
First of all, the democratically
elected government of Guatemala
imposed a land reform
act that affected
the interests of United Fruit
Company, one of the oldest
and most important clients
of the Dulles brothers.
And around the same time,
the government of Iran
nationalized the
Iranian oil industry,
which had as its
financial agent its bank,
a bank that was a long-time
client of the Dulles brothers.
And in fact, Allen Dulles was
on the board of that bank.
So, as private
lawyers, there was
nothing the Dulles
brothers could
do to punish Prime Minister
Mossadegh in Iran and President
Arbenz in Guatemala.
But as soon as they
came into office,
they begin plotting
against those two guys.
And within 18 months, both
of them had been overthrown.
And these were
operations both that
seemed like successes
at the time.
I mean, if you take
the one in Iran.
So we got rid of a guy we
didn't like-- Mossadegh--
and we replaced them
with a guy, The Shah, who
would do whatever we wanted.
So it seemed like
the perfect outcome.
Now when we look
back at it, it really
doesn't look like it
came out so successfully.
Of course, that
cool was followed
by 25 years of rising
repression under the Shah,
and then the explosion
of the late 1970s,
the emergence of this
fanatically anti-American
religious regime with which
we've had to deal ever since.
That is a result of the Dulles
brothers' original meddling
there in the early 1950s.
And you can trace the long-term
effects of these operations
all over the world.
One of the points of my
book is that although we
think of the 1950s
as a period of peace,
that's a mistake, that actually
the Dulles brothers were waging
an unbroken world war
during that period.
We didn't see it,
because it was mainly
fought quietly
under the surface.
And when it did break
out into public view,
like it did in Guatemala
or in Indonesia,
we were told that it was
just a local uprising
and that we weren't involved.
Also the theater of
operations in this war
kept changing, from
Iran to Guatemala
to Vietnam to
Indonesia to the Congo
to Egypt to India to Cuba.
But the people on
the receiving end
were fully aware of what
was happening to them.
Vietnam is really a
great example, really
one of the most sobering
of all the ones I came up
with when researching the
career of these extraordinary
brothers.
John Foster Dulles,
it turns out,
was more responsible for
the US engagement in Vietnam
than any single individual.
The story is this.
In 1954, the big powers
convened in Geneva
to decide what to
do about Indochina.
Just as they were
meeting, Ho Chi Minh
was winning his big victory
at the Dien Bien Phu.
This led the French to
decide with great pain,
we're finished.
We have to withdraw.
We lost the war.
The British also realized,
it's over for us there.
And they all arrived at Geneva
along with the other powers
with the idea that Ho
Chi Minh, unfortunately,
had earned on the
battlefield his right
to one sliver of Indochina.
Within a couple
of days, it became
clear to John Foster Dulles who
headed the American delegation
what was going to happen
at the conference,
that they were ready to concede
a chance for Ho Chi Minh
to compete freely
for power in Vietnam.
Foster Dulles could
not accept this.
He believed that just
because the French could not
defeat Ho Chi Minh
and the British
hadn't been able to do it
and the Japanese had failed
to do it, that didn't mean
the Americans couldn't do it.
So he left the conference.
It's the only time in history
that an American Secretary
of State has walked out of a
major international conference
in the middle.
And he flew home, and he
told his brother Allen,
you've got to start a
major operation in Vietnam.
We are going to
fight Ho Chi Minh.
If that one guy had not made
that one decision on that one
day as he was flying
home from Geneva,
we might have avoided the
entire American involvement
in Vietnam.
And you can't even wrap your
mind around how different
America and Vietnam
and the world
might be under
those circumstances.
Now one thing that's curious
about the Dulles brothers
as I get to know them, of
course, living with them
more or less as I did
while writing this book,
is that although they saw the
world in the exact same way,
their personalities were
actually quite different.
one of the worst things
about having these two
brothers in there
was that they had
come up and grown up
and seen the world
and arrived at beliefs
that were identical.
So they converted the
foreign policy-making process
into a kind of at
reverberating echo chamber
for their own shared beliefs.
They never consulted
anyone outside.
They were actually highly
unimaginative people
intellectually.
That's another great
lesson for today.
What they believed
when they were 12
is essentially what they
believed their whole lives.
So they saw the world
very much in the same way
from the Wall Street and
covert action perspective.
But their personalities
were polar opposites.
So John Foster Dulles,
the older brother,
was dour, arrogant,
self-righteous, socially
awkward, very
unpleasant dinner guest.
He couldn't remember
people's names around him.
I read in one book even his
friends didn't like him.
He had these awkward
habits, like he
used to drink Old
Overholt, rye whisky,
and he would stir it
with his index finger
and then put the finger
in his mouth and suck
on it for a while and
then stir it some more.
At one point,
Winston Churchill got
very irritated at how Dulles'
rhetorical anger always
produced confrontations.
And he described Foster
Dulles as "the only bull
who carries his own China
shop around with him."
But I actually liked Harold
MacMillan's comment better--
another British prime minister.
He was talking
about Foster Duller,
and he said "his
speech was slow,
but it easily kept pace
with his thoughts."
But Allen Dulles was
completely different.
Allen Dulles was a
sparkling conversationalist
and a great dinner guest
who loved fine wine
and played tennis and had a
hundred affairs with everybody
from Claire Booth Luce
to the Queen of Greece.
He was a sparkling presence on
the Washington social scene,
as he had been in
New York earlier.
And I think this was important
because, as head of the CIA,
which is in a new
agency in Washington,
Allen Dulles was
not only the chief
of the invisible
government, he was also
the ambassador of the
invisible government
to the visible government.
And I think there must
have been a lot of people
at those Georgetown parties who
left thinking to themselves,
we really don't know
what the CIA is.
We don't know what it does.
But if it's run by such a
wonderful guy like Allen,
it can't be doing much wrong.
Now one reason that the Dulles
brothers were so successful
is that they did work in tandem.
So Foster Dulles would
make public statements
about the government
of Country X seeming
like it was being
dangerously infiltrated
by leftists or Communists.
Meanwhile, Allen would work to
foment trouble in that country.
Then, as trouble
would break out,
Foster would make
speeches saying
we see that the
people of Country X
are very unhappy with their
leftist inspired regime.
And we have nothing
to do with it.
And then finally, those
regimes would collapse,
as happened in Guatemala, Foster
would then go on the radio
afterwards and say, thus,
the problem has been solved
by the Guatemalan
people themselves.
This approach was
quite successful
and it was fully supported
by President Eisenhower.
Now, Eisenhower was a
fervent and intense supporter
of covert action and
clandestine operations.
Why was that?
We don't know, because he didn't
talk about this in public.
In those days, you
could really believe
that those secrets would
go with you to your grave.
For reasons we all know,
nobody believes that anymore.
But I think we can speculate
on a couple of facts regarding
Eisenhower.
First of all, we
now know, as was not
clear to anybody in the
'50s, that covert operations
and secret actions had a good
role in winning World War II.
The breaking of the Nazi codes
and other secret operations
were not known to the
public, but of course,
Eisenhower, as commander, must
been aware of all of them.
And the other reason I think
that Eisenhower might have been
so strongly in favor
of covert action
was that he would have seen it
as a kind of a peace project.
Imagine this was a guy
who had to send people out
to die by the thousands.
This must have weighed on him.
And here was a way to get rid of
a foreign government you didn't
like with just the loss
of maybe a few lives.
And none of them
would be American.
And it would hardly
cost anything.
So he must thought this
was a great solution.
He shared with the
Dulles brothers
one huge historical
misjudgement.
And that was he had no concept
of what we now call blowback.
It never occurred to the Dulles
brothers or to Eisenhower
that their interventions
in foreign countries
would have such profound
effects years and years later.
It never dawned on
them that by deciding
to confront Ho Chi
Minh in Vietnam,
we would be setting off a
process in which millions would
die, or that Civil War
would descend on Guatemala,
or that Iran would become
a giant geopolitical enemy
of ours all over the world.
They really had, perhaps
because of their belief
in American exceptionalism,
this sense that the United
States was in some
way above history,
that the tendency of history
to come back and bite people
and nations years later
didn't apply to us.
It's something
like believing you
can beat your child every
single day until he's 18,
and then on his 18th birthday,
you give him a big hug
and say, OK, forget
all that now.
Just go and to be a
normal happy person.
I think in an indirect way, that
was a belief that Eisenhower
and the Dulles brothers had.
Now, if they could be
here to defend themselves
against this charge, I can
imagine one good observation
they might make.
They might say, we
didn't know this.
We didn't know that covert
operations can add huge effects
50 years later, because 50
years before we were in power,
there hadn't been any
covert operations.
But this at least is an
argument we don't have today.
We now have many examples to
show us long-term consequences.
And the Dulles
brothers have been
generous in leaving us
quite a number of those.
I think the Dulles
brothers made a couple
of other historical misjudgments
from which we can learn today.
One is that they were
absolutely opposed
to any direct contact
between the United States
and any of its geopolitical
rivals or enemies.
They were absolutely opposed
to any summit meetings
between American leaders
and Soviet leaders.
They were in power
just a couple of months
when Stalin died in the Soviet
Union at the beginning of 1953.
It only took a few
months after that
before peace feelers began
emerging from the Kremlin
to see if the
United States might
be interested in a
changed relationship.
At the end of 1953,
a summit conference
was held in Bermuda by what
was then called The Big Three.
That was France, Britain,
and the United States.
And there, one of
the agenda items
was a request by Malekov
who was the temporary leader
in the Kremlin, for what he
could call a Big Four summit.
So France, Britain, United
States and Soviet Union.
Let's all get together.
Churchill, who was there,
thought this was a great idea.
The French were favoring it.
But John Foster Dulles
was totally against.
He vetoed it.
No summit was held.
It was Foster Dulles's
idea that the Cold War was
built on a paradigm
of conflict and then
once you would sit down with
your arrival across the table,
you convey to the American
public above all, this view
that the Soviets are just
normal people like anybody else.
And maybe they have an idea.
Or they'll listen to our ideas.
And maybe we can work out some
kind of a compromise with them.
They felt that just
the germ of that idea
would undermine their whole
approach to the world, which
was based on the fact that
there were only two blocks,
and you could not fail to
take sides between them.
And that leads into
what I think was
the third great misjudgement
that the Dulles brothers made,
another one for which
we're still paying today.
That is, they
completely misjudged
the nature of Third
World nationalism.
Now, this is a period
after World War
II when many countries
were emerging
from colonialism
of different kinds.
They were looking
for their place
in a very turbulent new world.
And many some were
led by people who
recognized huge needs at home.
They did not want to waste
their political energies
on getting involved
in the Cold War.
So their foreign policy
was we're not pro-Moscow,
we're not pro-Washington.
We're not interested.
We don't care.
This was a point of
view that was completely
unacceptable to
John Foster Dulles.
He even used the word immoral
to describe neutralism.
So essentially what
the Dulles policy did
was drive away from
the United States
leaders and nations that
were eager to be our friends.
We looked around the
world at neutralists
and saw not leaders who were
trying to embody new people's
emerging onto the world
stage, but secret pawns
of the Kremlin.
I'm talking about people
like Mossadegh in Iran,
Arbenz in Guatemala,
Sukarno in Indonesia,
Lumumba in the Congo, Nehru
in India, Nasser in Egypt.
These were all people
who were trying
to embody national
struggles at home
and had as essential parts
of their political ideology
nonalignment.
At one point, Allen Dulles
had this project for Nasser.
We are going to take
Arab nationalism
and we're going to turn it
to a pro-American ideal.
We can have Arab nationalism
plus pro-American sentiment
together.
This is a complete
misunderstanding
of what Arab nationalism is.
That's the whole point.
We're not going to be aligned
with any outside force.
That's page one, line one.
But the Americans
couldn't understand that.
So as a result, we set
in motion processes
that robbed us of long-term
potential geo-strategic
friends.
And these are all lessons that I
think have relevance for today.
First of all, we need
to take other countries
on their own terms,
and not insist
that they be for
us or against us.
Secondly, I think the
idea of not talking
to rivals and enemies has
gotten us into a lot of trouble.
I would say this now
in the last few months,
we've seen a couple of
interesting developments.
First of all, the President
of the United States
wanted to bomb a
foreign country, Syria,
but many Americans were against
it and many members of Congress
were against it.
And it didn't happen.
That was a pretty big event.
I can't remember
any time in my life
when the President of the states
wanted to bomb another country,
but he didn't do it because
people were against it.
Usually it's the
other way around.
And then, soon after that, the
President of the United States
picked up the phone and spoke
with the President of Iran.
And we are now involved in a
negotiating process with Iran.
So when those kind of
things happen, I ask myself
did the Dulles era just end?
Like within the last
couple of months?
I don't know.
I'm thinking maybe
this is the result
of us having had some very
bad luck in our last few wars,
and maybe people are a
little bit punch drunk.
As soon as we get
the smelling salts,
maybe America will be back
making the same mistakes again.
But.
I like to think
that as time passes,
were able to learn from
some of our past mistakes.
Now, I finished my book
with an observation
about what I consider to
be a great masterpiece
of 20th century political art.
When I'm teaching, I don't like
to measure anything like this
to my students, because they
always open up their iPads
right away.
But those of you
that have the book,
it's the last panel
in the photo insert.
Let me just talk
briefly about it.
So in 1954, the Dulles
brothers directed the overthrow
of the government of
Jacobo Arbenz in Guatemala.
This caused huge outrage
in Latin America,
including in Mexico, which
borders on Guatemala,
and where there's a big
anti-imperialist tradition.
At that time, Frida
Kahlo was lying
on her deathbed, forbidden
to leave the house.
But she was so angry at the
US overthrow of the Guatemalan
government, she told Diego
Rivera, we're going out.
We're going to march
in the protest parade.
And you can find a photo
of Diego Rivera pushing
Frida Kahlo in the
front of the protest
parade against the
American coup in Guatemala.
She died 11 days later.
And Diego Rivera set out to
paint this fantastic mural.
So it's 16 feet long on linen,
and it tells the whole story.
So right in the middle,
you see John Foster Dulles
with a big grin on his face,
Allen Dulles right behind him
with his head over on
Foster's shoulder with money
coming out of the packet on
his belt, if you can see that.
Foster is shaking hands
with the Guatemalan
he has placed in as
the new dictator.
You see the archbishop
blessing at all,
while out workers are bending
under the weight of bananas
stems they're carrying
on to a freighter
with the American flag on it.
And dead Guatemalan children
are in the background.
And of course, Eisenhower's
big smiling face
is on the bomb
right in the middle.
So Allen Dulles
loved this picture.
He actually had copies made
up to hand it out to people.
He loved the fact
that Diego Rivera
was portraying him this way.
Diego Rivera, of
course, was a Communist,
so it worked out well for Allen.
While I was finishing
this book, I
decided-- I know this
picture very well.
I've stared at it on
the internet for hours.
I know every inch of it.
But I want to go and
see it in real life.
So I have to find out--
there's various Diego Rivera
museums in Mexico-- I have to
find out which one it's in.
I'm going to go find it.
And I made a trip to Mexico.
And I started
making phone calls.
But I couldn't find it.
And one thing led to another.
I had to leave.
I lost it.
Then I had to do a long
investigative project.
And I found out the following.
That picture disappeared
in the 1950s.
What happened was that
Diego Rivera donated it
to the people of
the Soviet Union.
But the Soviets didn't
like Diego Rivera,
because he wasn't considered
a real Communist over there.
He was too Latin American.
He had different
ideas every day.
He wasn't doctrinaire enough.
So the next thing you know,
the painting just disappeared.
And nobody followed it up.
And it wasn't the early '90s,
that a group of art historians
in Mexico started a kind
of a project to find it.
And sure enough,
they located it.
It's in the basement of the
Pushkin Museum in Moscow.
That's where it ended up.
So I had to decide,
OK, Mexico's nearby.
Moscow, very far away.
But am I going to make
a special trip to Moscow
just to stand in
front of this picture.
So I decide yes,
I'm going to do it.
So through a long
process, I finally
got in touch with
the deputy curator
for whatever-- the
Pushkin Museum.
And I got back an email, and
it says, if you come to Moscow,
I will take you to the
basement and show you
the roll on which this
painting is rolled up.
But I cannot unroll it because
we don't have the space.
So this means that this
painting is essentially--
I don't want to
say lost forever.
It's still there.
I guess it's not deteriorating.
But nobody can see it.
Nobody can benefit from it.
So it's my new fantasy that we
should resurrect that picture.
And I know exactly where
I want it to stand.
I think it should be the
centerpiece of Dulles
International Airport.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN KINZER: It
would be the way for us
to look at the picture and ask
ourselves the real questions.
Take the air brush
off these guys' faces,
and see if they
don't have something
that they can still teach us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHEN KINZER: Great.
I'm more than happy to
take some questions.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was reading
recently that democracy
has been spreading
across the globe.
I skeptically that heard that as
a message from our own culture,
but this was from-- I don't
remember which organization
or which organizations were
rating various countries as
whether they were
democratic or not,
and showing the
rate of progressing.
Do you think the Dulles
brothers promoted
that someone actually pursuing
their goals made no difference,
or actually hindered it
by causing more blowback?
STEPHEN KINZER: I
think there's no doubt
that the Dulles brothers'
net effect was reducing
the level of democracy
in the world.
And I've asked myself this
question, given how outspokenly
committed they were to the
ideals of liberty and freedom,
how could it be that they
would arrive in countries that
were relatively free, like,
say, Iran or Guatemala,
and when they leave,
it's under a dictatorship
that becomes quite brutal.
I think it's because of this.
I think the Dulles
brothers had to develop
an idea of democracy, a
definition of democracy that
would allow them
to say, actually
Guatemala was more democratic
under the military junta
then it was under the
elected government of Arbenz,
and that the Shah was actually
a more democratic leader who
allowed more freedom
than the elected
government of Mossadegh.
So here's the definition
I think they came up with.
Their idea was a
country is free,
if it has the fundamental
freedom that allows everybody
to trade, companies can come
and buy, companies can sell.
Anybody can start a business.
There's no heavy
restriction on commerce.
Foreign trade is welcome.
That's a sign of democracy.
Now if you use that
standard, then maybe
you can say that Guatemala
was more democratic
under the dictatorship,
because then there
were no taxes on United Fruit.
The phone company and
the electric company
could charge whatever
rates they wanted.
They were not being bothered
by child labor laws and all
these other regulations that
the Arbenz government tried
to place on them, which
certainly would have restricted
the freedom of the
United Fruit Company.
So I think this is
the argument that they
developed for themselves.
And it allowed them to replace
elected governments that
allowed civil rights with
unelected governments
that repressed civil rights and
still go to church on Sunday
and thank God that they were
not evil like other men.
AUDIENCE: Well, so
given that, where
do you think that
these guys would
fall on a socio-pathology scale?
Because having such
that background
that they took one part
of it from but left out
the whole other part
of Christianity,
these men were both responsible
for deaths of individuals,
both indiscriminate
and very discriminate,
where their word went to
have these people killed.
Their treatment of
the rest of the world
was based upon what was
really good for the Dulles
brothers themselves
and their friends.
Allen was a huge
adulterer who had
no care about his
consequences for that.
And maybe other evil things
related to internal problems
in our country, like
regime change at home.
STEPHEN KINZER: Yeah, I
think the Dulles brothers can
be held responsible for
an approach to politics
that I think still
is very powerful.
Every time I go to Washington,
which is as rarely as possible,
I am impressed with how powerful
is the force that brings people
towards the foreign
policy consensus
and how narrow is the spectrum
of acceptable opinions
on foreign policy issues.
You have to accept an entire
string of assumptions.
Otherwise, you're
thought of as some kind
of a wacko who will never got
a lunch invitation in this town
again.
The Dulles brothers
were not thoughtful.
They were not imaginative.
They just embraced cliches
and existing paradigms.
I hold this against them.
Actually, for all
their opportunity
and their education, they were
actually quite narrow-minded.
And I think maybe
their background
afflicted them a little
bit with that in this way.
One thing that I think is
very important to understand
if you want to understand
the world and statesmanship
is that sometimes things go
well and sometimes things
don't go well.
There's a lot of
problems out there.
And that's the way life is.
But life was never like that
for the Dulles brothers.
For them, and for the
people that they knew,
which was exclusively their own
class, nothing ever went wrong.
The catastrophic
reversal of fortune,
the sudden loss of everything,
the collapse of all hopes,
the family that falls apart--
this didn't happened to them.
They were really
isolated from this.
And I think maybe from
this, unconsciously,
they assimilated this view
that everything's always
going to work out fine.
After all, we're America.
And in the end, it
comes out great.
The can-do mentality is
a very positive thing.
It's what built America.
And it's what
built this company.
It tells us that we
can overcome obstacles,
posed by other countries,
by other peoples,
by environment, by technology.
But there are some
obstacles that you
can't overcome just because
you want to overcome them.
Many obstacles that face
United States and the world
are deep-seated ones that
are posed by cultures
of other countries, that have
existed long before the United
States even emerged
on this earth.
And that's the dark side
of the can-do mentality.
The can-do mentality tells
you if you're American,
and you really want
something enough,
and you really, really work
hard, you're going to get it.
This is a nice thing
to believe, but it also
has a negative side.
AUDIENCE: Did they-- you're kind
of alluding to this-- but did
they ever study history?
Or had the history been
written yet or interpreted yet
of prior US governments that
played like this and then
bad things started to happen?
So like Teddy Roosevelt
and his treatment
of Japan, Korea and China.
Were people aware
of the ramifications
of that then 40 years later?
STEPHEN KINZER: First
of all, I don't believe
that in that particular
episode, Americans
had any understanding that
Roosevelt's intervention
in Japan and Korea
actually set in motion,
in some ways, what
led to Pearl Harbor.
Even now, I think few
people are aware of that.
But in a more general
sense, you asked about
whether the Dulles
brothers had read history.
I guess they did, but I think
they were victim to something
that I think still
afflicts many Americans.
And that is the view
that history really
doesn't apply to us.
I think there's a view
that there's never
been a country like
the United States.
I read from Marco Rubio,
the Florida senator,
not only is this the
greatest country on earth,
this is the greatest
civilization
that has ever existed in
the history of the world.
I think this view does lead
you naturally to think, well,
of course, these
forces afflicted
the Persian empire
and the German empire
and the Chinese empire
centuries and centuries ago.
But that doesn't apply to us.
So I think even worse than
learning the wrong lessons
from history, is to believe
that history has no lessons
to teach you at all.
And I think maybe
this is something
that the Dulles
brothers fell victim to.
We had this phrase.
It came out in the
1940s by Henry Luce,
who was one of their
great comrades,
saying that the 20th
century was going
to be the American century.
Now it becomes our time
to be the powerhouse.
So we assimilated this
view that what's good
for the United States
is always going
to be what's good for the world.
And what's good for
the Dulles brothers
and the people they
knew and worked for
is what's good for
the United States.
And to a certain degree,
I think we're still
falling victim to that.
AUDIENCE: That's a
little bit unfair
and perhaps a
caricature, I think.
I mean, George Kennan
wrote quite a bit
about containment in early
'40s, late to mid '30s.
And you may argue that
the Dulles-- I don't
know much about
this book at all.
And I haven't read the history
behind these two. gentlemen.
But it's certainly true
that the calculus of power
involves an appraisal
of your adversary.
And in some sense, a
nuclear power, I think,
we deal with quite
differently than one
that doesn't, just
to make an example.
So I think it's kind of unfair
to say that Americans believe
or there's this thought that
we can just willy-nilly exert
our power, because
in some sense,
I think a lot of the '50s and
late-'60s were driven by this
view of containing the
social regime that was viewed
as expansionist by all
intelligence that we could
gather.
So could you speak
to a little bit,
to maybe the intelligent part
of the argument rather than
the caricature?
STEPHEN KINZER: Well,
Kennan and others definitely
had a view for how to
manage the Cold War.
And Kennan was fired
from the State Department
by John Foster Dulles,
because there wasn't room
for both of them.
And in fact, John
Foster Dulles, who
wrote Eisenhower speeches during
the 1952 presidential campaign
and wrote the Republican
platform on foreign policy,
was an explicit opponent
of the containment
idea, which he called immoral.
And his alternative was what
became known as rollback.
He called it the
"liberation policy,"
that we're going to
go back and roll back
Communism where it now exists.
Now, once coming
into office, he never
pursued that rollback
or liberation policy.
In fact, while continuing
to condemn containment,
he effectively embraced it.
And we saw that twice.
In East Germany in
1953, workers rose up
against their
Communist government.
If we were interested
in rollback,
that would have been
the moment to help them.
It happened again
in 1956 in Hungary.
Tragically, those
people had to listen
to the rhetoric from
Washington and believed
that Washington actually
supported rollback.
We actually didn't.
It was all rhetorical.
But I think that after
coming to office,
the Dulles brothers did
conclude, with Eisenhower
serving as a calming
influence in this case,
rollback is not going to happen.
You cannot attack
the Soviet Union.
We're not invading China.
But still they felt the
need for striking back.
There was, as you say, a
sense that the Soviet empire
and sphere of influence
was relentlessly expanding.
You can argue about whether
that was really true or not,
but at the moment
it seemed that way.
And so, unable to strike
against the real enemy,
the Dulles brothers
then had to go strike
against the secondary enemy
that they could overthrow,
like countries like
Iran and Guatemala.
So I would say that
the Dulles brothers'
sin in assessing
Communism, their mistake,
was not that they exaggerated
its essentially evils.
The way they portrayed the
Soviet Union and China,
in terms of the way
they ruled domestically
was not exaggerated.
Those were just as evil
regimes as the Dulles brothers
portrayed them to be.
But I think the mistake
the Dulles brothers made
was to transfer their
feelings about those countries
to places like
Guatemala and Iran
and Indonesia, where those
circumstances did not obtain.
But the need to have
a victory and to seem
like we were pushing
back, I think
led them, for reasons I
think we can understand,
to carry out actions
that in the long run
actually wound up fomenting
and supporting the forces
that we were trying to crush.
Just to give one
small example, we
crushed the Guatemalan
revolution in 1954.
That was a peaceful revolution,
so a land reform project.
During that period
of 1953 and '54,
many socialist and leftist
and idealistic young Latin
Americans came to Guatemala
to see what was happening.
How do you reform a country?
One of them was a
young Argentine doctor
named Che Guevara.
Che Guevara was
there at the time
the US overthrew the
government of Guatemala.
It happens right after the end
of the movie, "The Motorcycle
Diaries."
If it goes on 10 more
minutes, he's in Guatemala.
He gets arrested.
He has to take refuge
in the Mexican embassy.
And finally he gets out.
He gets back to Mexico.
That's where he
meets Fidel Castro.
Castro says to him, what
happened in Guatemala?
And Che tells them, the idiots
that were running Guatemala
thought they could reform
society with a democracy.
They allowed the free newspapers
to function and the army
not to be decapitated
and student groups
and professional organizations
to thrive in a democracy.
Of course, the CIA came
in, paid them all off
and overthrew them.
So when we come
to power, let's be
sure there's no free society,
no civil rights, no opposition
parties, and no dissent.
That's the lesson that
ultimately came out
of what we thought we were
doing for freedom in Guatemala.
AUDIENCE: I lived
through the disaster
that was the '90s in Moscow.
And I have this impression
that is so refreshing
to hear from somebody who knows
what they're talking about
that the United States tends
to be inept in foreign policy.
So I wonder what would your
advice, what your vision be,
to the relationship of US
and Russia going forward.
STEPHEN KINZER:
Well, first of all,
let me comment on one
of your observations.
And this is something
I did come away
believing from my study
of the Dulles brothers.
So Allen Dulles has this
reputation as the Great Spy
and the greatest spy
master of all time,
and Foster Dulles the great
wise man of the 20th century.
Actually, every single operation
they launched either failed
or almost failed.
The Iran and Guatemala ones
seemed like they were lost.
Then they won at
the last minute.
And the others all failed.
They couldn't overthrow Sukarno.
They couldn't overthrow Nasser.
They couldn't overthrow Castro.
So actually, they
were a lot more
like bumblers than super spies.
I hate to stand in front of
you and talk about Russia,
because it's not my
field of expertise.
I would just say that I'm torn.
On the one hand,
I love Pussy Riot.
I want them to be the junta
that runs the country.
That's my heart speaking.
On the other hand, my study
of the world, particularly
countries that I
know a lot, like Iran
and that part of the
world, Central America,
has led me to believe in a
great axiom from Shakespeare
that sometimes it's
better to bear those ills
that we know than fly to
others that we know not of.
So I find the style of
leadership of Putin intensively
frustrating.
I couldn't live under that.
On the other hand, I
can imagine a Russia
that is Gagastan times 1,000.
And then we might be
looking back and saying,
couldn't we get
somebody like Putin?
So I can see how things could
get a lot better than they are.
But having watched
what I've watched
and remembering that it
was only like two years ago
when we were looking
at Egypt and saying
this is the greatest
blow for freedom
since the French Revolution,
that maybe sometimes
we have to weigh in
the factor of stability
as a key determinant
of human safety.
If you don't have
a stable society,
you have no framework within
which to build anything.
Now any tyrant can use
that as an argument also.
Where do you draw the line?
That's the question for
citizens of any country.
And I just close by
saying this, as we
are taking this discussion
into the modern moment.
I think here we are in a country
where levels of democracy
are declining.
I mean, we can certainly
see it in our own lifetimes.
The United States
has become a society
with less access
for ordinary people
to politics and less
social mobility.
There are some very distressing
trends in this country.
When it comes to foreign
policy, however, I'm
noticing something that
I find kind of curious.
And it does refer me back
a little to the Dulles era.
And it's this.
Traditionally, on the
spectrum of people
who want to use
American military power
and send the Army
every time there's
trouble somewhere,
the more you believe
like that, the more
you're on the right.
And the more you believe that
the United States shouldn't
be intervening in other
parts of the world,
the more you're on the left.
I don't think this
is true anymore.
I think that now there's
a growing consensus
at different spots around
the political spectrum
that a humbler,
less promiscuous,
less lustful approach to the
outside world might in the end
work out better for
the United States.
We've learned some graphic
lessons in the last few years.
Again, whether these
lessons are profound
or whether they just represent
a swing of the pendulum,
I think remains to be seen.
But we are at a moment now
when I think a number of people
are beginning to rethink
some fundamental instincts
about America and wondering if
we protect our security better
over the long run by
being less intrusive.
If that's true, maybe
we are coming to an end
to the Dulles era.
And the only thing
the remains will
be to bring the mural
back to Dulles Airport.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]